لف الهدوء المحافظات الاردنيه اعمال شغب
احتجاجا على قرار الحكومه رفع اسعار
المحروقات خلال هذه الاحتجاجات وفي حي
الحسنيه في محافظه معان قتل مسؤول في جهاز
شرطه المحافظه واصيب ضابطين اخرا على يد
مجهولين قتل الضابط دفع بالاجهزه الامنيه
الى ارسال تعزيزات الى المنطقه التي اشعل
فيها المتظاهرون الاطارات وقطعوا الطرقات
فيما قال بيان للشرطه ان الضابطه قتل اثره
عرضه للاصابه بعيار ناريهم في منطقه الراس
على يد مجموعه من المخربين والخارجين عن
القانون لحسب البيان
امتدت الى محافظات اخرى في المملكه ووفقا
شهود عيان فان شباب اشعل النار في اطارات
سيارات على طريق سريعا رئيسي بين العاصمه
والبحر الميت في الجنوب الغربي للاردن
الامر الذي عرق لا حركه المرور وفي هل
البلاد قرب الحدود مع سوريا اشتبك شباب مع
الشرطه في عده احياء في مدينه اربد حيث
استخدمت الشرطه الغزل للدموع لتفريق
الشباب الذين رشقوها بالحجاره ونظم عشرات
الشبان احتجاجا في حي طفيله في العاصمه
عمان ورددوا شعارات مناهضه للحكومه وكان
شبح الاحتجاجات والاضرابات قد خيم على
المشهد في الاردن خلال ال 10 ايام الماضيه
بعد ان اغلقت المتاجر في معان وعده مدن
اخرى ابوابها الاربعاء تضامنا مع مطالبات
واضرابات للسائق شاحنات نقل البضائع ثلاثه
حافلات النقل العام وسيارات الاجره لخفض
اسعار الوقود حنان المصري العربيه